[Music]
in the clink in the slammer yeah I'm
doing hard time for a crime that I
committed back in 2009 see violent games
lead to crime wish I knew from the start
before I ever got involved and play a
Mario car I was hugging the turns even
items for thrill he's seen a total
damage by shell since that last oil
spill if something happens to you brain
doing virtual wrongs woke up the next
morning and it wasn't too long for I was
dropping bananas upon every street
hurling Turtles hurtin every single
person I see then I was roar aging that
plumbers nobody could stop everyone
princesses off the road so much I joined
the paparazzi now I'm in prison too in
20 to life
how could such a game be legal man the
danger is right where my fate is see you
will be doing right because I'm playing
violent video games tonight and the
things I've been doing like it's a
tragedy I'm gonna being me up another
time my life went astray why you're in a
World War 2 game back in 2008 I was only
playing a minute then I felt an uneasy
right after playing I can turn the
Japanese later I would play the judges
to win every race it's just what happens
when you play too many games by EA now
I'm doing life with no chance of parole
why didn't anybody ban these games I was
out of know and I think SC you won't be
doing right because I'm playing video
and the things I've been doing like it's
a tragedy I'm gonna be an expert here
and forgive me for stalling violent
video games the stats are appalled just
look at this graph and as you can tell
this game plays increased youth crime
has as well it's gone down well who
needs a charts of 400 grand alone so you
know that I'm smart like a guy leaving
the moil you're missing the point
freedoms when you only get to play the
games we're not wealthy
if sale won't be doing that because I'm
playing bottom video games and the
things I've been doing like it's a
tragedy I'm gonna be